there were vampires there were
werewolves there was love need we say
more bringing five twilight movies to
the screens saw actors getting concussed
on set flesh made out of cheese blood
made out of strawberry jam driverless
trucks and we're just getting started
why did mackenzie foy make a huge bonus
why was kristen stewart wearing butt
padding
why was taylor lautner putting something
in my mouth every two hours we know you
want to know so hold on tight because
we're going twi hard
number one werewolves vampires oh my
poor kristen stewart had quite the scare
when she feared she was going to be
attacked
by an all too two-in-character jackson
rathbone helen lutz and peter faccinelli
had to learn just how strong rathbone
was the hard way one take gone wrong saw
the actor actually breaking free and
knocking over elizabeth racer seriously
dude number two ooh neck tasty
in this case chomping into his co-star
actually wasn't so bad
that juicy hunk of flesh is actually
delicious cheese
a nice perk for pattinson how many hunks
of mozzarella are we guessing he went
through
it's like a drug to me
number three how tough is kellen lutz
well he's tough enough to give another
actor a concussion the performers were
rehearsing and got a bit too carried
away and honestly they just missed their
marks let's punching too low and
rathbone not moving far enough out of
the way
it took a while for the actor to
actually stop and once they did radbone
wasn't completing full sentences so off
to the hospital he went come on it's
just a game number four
joyride but make it tropical
robert pattinson not only learned how to
drive a car but a boat as well for
twilight although whether or not he
learned how to maneuver water vehicles
safely is questionable since he did
crash while filming in front of
everybody alright so vampires not so
good with the water sports got it number
five vampires must have perfect teeth
it's a requirement at least for the
twilight production team since they had
pattinson get some dental work done
before filming but rebel that he is
pattinson didn't wear his brace and
ended up damaging his teeth permanently
that's the most selfish thing i'll ever
do number six
batter up
nikki reed has a pretty decent swing and
what's more
our girl can hit and perform with her
left hand
it was harder but looked better on
camera so what can you do
this isn't a life i would have chosen
for myself
number seven
yikes come on the first rule of being a
vampire is always stretch evidently
pattinson didn't get the message
the actor got the whole production into
some trouble after he pulled his butt
cheek during the very first shot
number eight
what in the world was christian stewart
doing wearing butt pads in the first
twilight film flaunting her backside
isn't a very bella trait but keeping it
safe was key for stuart the pads were
actually snuck in just to help soften
the blow for when she had to land on the
ice over and over and over number nine
sweet vampire tunes you know rudy
vampires make for excellent songwriters
sweet pattinson loved tickling those
ivories so much and everyone could
recognize his talents so he got to make
an already dreamy vampire even dreamier
thanks to nikki reed for sneakily
filming the actor playing on set to out
his talent to the crew number 10
that's suspicious
alright so is it normal for trucks and
forks to not need drivers
yeah we're talking about this log truck
that goes by with no human visible
inside
that's weird
they meet they act they kiss they fall
in love they are christian stewart and
robert pattinson who knew a long-term
relationship and worldwide fame could
all start just during a chemistry
makeout on catherine hardwick's bed i
had him actually audition at my house he
might not have known exactly what he was
getting himself into but pattinson was
prepared for anything he actually took a
quarter of a valium to calm himself down
for the audition
number 12
twilight was surprisingly authentic at
times the production designer for new
moon actually went to meet the quillet
executive council and he also happened
to be given a very special gift a drum
made by a girl from there and that drum
made the cut of the film a special
tribute of appreciation to the community
number 13.
chuck esme sorry sorry renesmee the
horrifying animatronic doll
sorry
well
you know exactly what we're talking
about the creepy animatronic doll
existed once upon a time but no one in
the caster crew was into it so thank
goodness it got the boot but not without
catching oh so much cringy animatronic
baby acting
twilight you know it'll never die
the ballet scene might just be the one
that gets the most screen time almost
all the screens in the movie have that
scene playing on it over and over again
but since they're in the background it's
not always obvious that's fun evidently
the volume was never turned up too high
number 15.
oh yeah she's rich mackenzie foy really
had a great payday when she booked
twilight she got her acting fees and of
course all the swearing penalty fees
we all got so comfortable with each
other that it was okay that everyone had
mouths like sailors this was pretty
handy for the young actress who heard a
whole lot of crass language but got paid
for it way to work the system foy
number 16.
how can someone get an article published
in a newspaper without any writing
experience
work in an art department for a movie
two of the authors for the twilight
newspapers lauren gigan and jeremy
stanbridge may not be real authors but
when you work in the art department you
can make it happen number 17.
edward was a few decades older than
bella so we can understand why his
clothing might be a bit more expensive
but in this case it's a bit ridiculous
oh she was a baby when we started robert
pattinson's suit was the most expensive
costume used in the movie while
christian stewart's prom dress cost just
20 bucks
number 18
i spy with my little eye
a quilt
the quilt rene gave bella an eclipse was
still around in breaking dawn part one
it's quite sweet really number 19.
look it's hard work to look this
perfectly tussled robert pattinson was
getting his hair trimmed once a week and
twice a day attention needed to be paid
to the luscious locks making sure they
looked perfectly floppy
remember that time anna kendrick
remembered that time she was in twilight
when she was she improvised this pretty
solid zombie speech
you know hilarity ensues so hendrick's
improv knows no bounds
number 21
after nearly being replaced because he
wasn't buff enough taylor lautner wasn't
going to let himself be anything but in
peak shape eating a lot but also putting
something in my mouth every two hours
it's hard to eat for a living we feel
you tate number 22 unfortunately eating
4 000 calories a day doesn't help when
someone wants to gain some height to
make up for his naturally short stature
lautner slipped in some heel lifts into
his shoes so he can look just a little
bit taller than christian stewart
and taylor is kind of like your little
brother reach for the stars buddy
number 23
while most of the people wearing contact
lenses are obvious we're looking at you
vampires christian stewart stuck with a
subtle look the actress has simple brown
contacts throughout the movies except
for in this perfectly rainy fight but
not because she didn't need them this
brutal rain was actually a bit of a
nightmare for the actors since it had to
be so intense to be seen on camera that
stewart's contacts got totally messed up
until she felt like she was literally
drowning those eyes got tinted in
post-production number 24 yeah you got
that yummy
okay so we know vampires love blood but
considering what it was made of in
twilight we can totally understand why
most of it was just corn syrup water and
red dye but the good stuff was reserved
for the newborn baby sensitive skin
leads to fake blood that was made out of
delicious spreads strawberry and cream
cheese what are we at brunch
the baby knowing when to take advantage
of a good situation kept trying to lick
the delicious blood off of itself
obviously it's edward cullen's kid
number 25. so instead of acknowledging
that yes
edward cullen could have moments of joy
and glimmers of a smile i got a
different color highlighter and
highlighted all the time when he frowned
but his sassy comeback wasn't going to
cut it as much as pattinson wanted a
broody edward the production did not and
the actor literally got a warning
letting him know that he wasn't as
irreplaceable as he thought he was
i came back off i came back after lunch
was like hi
[Music]
so irritate your eyes at first
okay so how many contact lenses did this
franchise go through exactly
christina patterson had her work cut out
for her literally painting every single
pair of the volturi contacts by hand to
get that perfect red number 27
didn't spend a lot of time auditioning
other women for bella okay well she did
spend a bit of time since michelle
trachenberg lily collins jennifer
lawrence and francis bean cobain also
auditioned for the part as for edward
well
it could have been henry cavill dustin
milligan dave franco jamie campbell
bauer michael welch shiloh fernandez and
jackson rathbone
christian stewart also almost wound up
with two twilight related exes since her
real-life boyfriend at the time michael
angarano nearly played mike in the
movies
number 28 can you spot the creatives
wedding guests included various members
of the production team which was pretty
smart for two reasons those involved
with the movie could have this special
scene as a sweet memory and they saved
money since they didn't have to pay for
as many extras screenwriter melissa
rosenberg co-producer bill bannerman and
producer wick godfrey all dove into the
twilight world even fabricating
elaborate backstories for their
temporary characters number 29
there were a lot of wigs in twilight and
considering most of the feedback
no one liked them a lot of regrets
nikki reed's wig was a bit of a savior
since all the dye made her natural hair
fall out but the style could be
questionable taylor lautner detested his
long wig christian stewart didn't care
for the one she wore and pattinson once
literally ripped out hair extensions
because he hated them so much or was he
just in character who knows
number 30.
i still wasn't entirely sure that i was
going to be an actor until after that
movie he wasn't sure he was going to be
an actor beforehand either sticking
around turned out pretty well it was far
from easy but gosh was it ever memorable
what's your favorite twilight filming
secret